quand tu as dix ans 27 ans j'ai bu comme
un homme normal en trois siècles
pas mal quand même ouais j'ai dû boire
pour trois siècles pour trois siècles et
tu buvais quoi particulièrement je
n'irais pas jusqu'à dire de tout mais
pas du matin au soir oui toutes sortes
de choses tu veux tout savoir dénoncer
pas une recette comme ça il n'y a pas de
recette le slinger par exemple tu as
fait comment slinger c'est du faux de la
menthe fraîche faut du cognac et puis du
du budget mais blanc turin et ça te
glisse parfaitement mon principe c'est
un ouais j'ai un seul bien autre chose
entre deux miss qui champagne devrait
enfin c'est tout ça c'est du passé tout
ça mais j'ai de la mémoire c'était
arrive tout s'était arrêté du jour au
lendemain de la seconde près sens en
kurde un sursaut en sortir
commençons d un taux très dense est une
irlande eire ouais pourquoi parce que tu
le supporte très mal quatre mois après
ce que tout le monde tu admires au début
du calcul courage il a quel volonté
machin et petit à petit quand tu
commandes de l'ôter jamais servi ouais
t'as peur soit tu as l'air d'un coup au
milieu des gens et je peux avoir me oui
oh ça arrive au dessus non mais après tu
risques de tomber dans un état plus ou
moins je veux pas dire déprécie quand
même tu payes la nôtre et avec quoi
tavel et le fois qu'elle explose et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ou non il
était bien fait au point de vue gamma gt
j'ai battu les records
ouais j'ai battu beau ranger de la
rentable mentalité niveau gainsbourg ah
non il était ridicule
ridicule non mais j'ai si tu veux j'ai
arrêté comme a fait james dean bois où
il fallait ouais voilà en tout cas tel
soutien des gens je vais te dire ne
trouva pas un petit reportage dans la
rue et les gens ted et je suis sûr que
ça te ferait plaisir de savoir que les
gens dans la rue était de tout coeur
avec toi dans ton c'est sympa là tu vas
voir
voici costard de stars
arrêtez de voir les maintenant trois
quatre ans cela dit c'est très dur et on
va l'encourager à ne pas rechuter on a
besoin de témoignages d'anciens
alcooliques
vous dites que vous buviez énormément et
qui m'attend c'est complètement arrêté
de boire et n'avait jamais rechuté pour
l'encourager à ne pas rechuter d'accord
dire ça parce qu'on a besoin des gens et
personnes venues lui dire quoi non nous
on vous mettra un cache sur les yeux à
nouveau écouter l'excusé ne me suis pas
alcoolique vois pas pourquoi je vais
raconter des choses comme ça pour une
émission le fou je dire je tourne
monsieur vous avez arrêté de boire
depuis combien d'années mais pas arrêté
de boire je n'ai jamais vu j'ai quand
même une belle tranche de pochtrons
monsieur au montage on comprend on dira
vous êtes alcoolique
combien de litres de vin par jour à 3
litres et demi ça vient encore des
séquelles aujourd'hui un petit peu on
est un petit peu je tiens encore de je
tremble un peu d'accord des fautes de
goût immonde genre écharpe verte sur le
voyait encore je me rends pas compte
enfin content du tout vous dites parfois
c'est dur je suis tenté de boire un
petit coup dur parfois c'est dur je suis
tenté ça m'arrive de temps en temps quoi
à part la scène house aller j'ai gueulé
dans le coin pour montrer les fléaux
d'alcoolisme
allez-y
l'image terrible qui je l'espère
aideront ge à cannes plus jamais boire
une goutte d'alcool
voilà s'il a effectivement deux en deux
ans ils ce sont les alcooliques anonymes
qui m'ont aidé les amis m'ont pas aidé
la littérature n'a pas aidé baudelaire
ne va pas aider puisqu'il dit il faut
toujours être ivre de vin de poésie ou
de vertu
boehler baudelaire le jeu a lancé le
poète
j'ai plus de souvenirs charles
baudelaire la littérature française le
dieu quels conseils donneriez-vous à
jacques dutronc pour qu'il arrête
définitivement de bois avant qu'il ne
refuse jamais de penser qu'il est
jacques dutronc qui l'a sûrement déjà
fait des choses difficiles moi j'ai pas
vu son van gogh qui pense avant guingamp
gauclin draps on va faire la scène de la
rechute vous faites semblant de boire
voilà meilhan le venge en leur nom
ressemblant voilà l'image d'une rechute
terrible et oui il en met partout c'est
pathétique
ouais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu